colin thanks conan how are you oh yeah
you know let's talk
okay well i'd like to start by saying i
don't like that guitar for you
because it's a little bit uh it's a
little bit flashy you know what i mean
i see you more with like a kind of a you
know a van morrison acoustic thing you
know yeah yeah
yeah no no why is it there let me tell
you something it's not even my guitar
and this is the thing about you colin
you are very perceptive
deceptively so this is not my guitar
uh the guy that sets up our stage just
said it there it's his guitar
i don't own a red guitar i don't have a
flashy guitar
no there you go of course not no
honestly even an electric guitar is a
little bit of a you know
indulgence that irish people should not
be involved in you don't think the irish
deserve to play an electric guitar
i just don't you think we're you think
we're sell
so self-hating and self-loathing
that the only thing we can do is play a
guitar that hasn't been electrified
yeah like oh look at this thinks he's
pretty good for himself he's plugged in
his guitar
oh look at him he thinks he's a tall
puppy plugging in the guitar
oh mr fancy pants speaking of guitars
and irish people
you have to admit they put bono bono
was the king of the world and irish
people
put him back where he shut he he shut
down
you think they shut him down they they
they totally did
yeah but like because he was getting so
cocky wearing glasses getting a little
flashy
dressing flashy and now he's back to
like listen i'm just here to play
and i'm gonna start trouble irish arrest
here's what the yes exactly the irish
don't like it if one of their own makes
it
in any way that's why i've been very
careful in my career
to have some success but not too much
yeah well look who you're talking i'm in
the same way and you got to
deprecate yourself and you're fine
that's all that matters yeah wouldn't
you tell me that thing about
the irish that's the whole thing about
boston when i go back to boston they're
like oh
think you're a big guy huh you're like i
just i just ordered a latte that's all i
did
i didn't cause any trouble i'm just
eating a hot dog i didn't
i didn't say anything i used to do a
routine in boston only i do it where i
talk about how every other city
they go you know st louis like john
hamm's from here
and so and so so-and-so's from here i go
you go to boss you go hey ben affleck's
from here they got
him my friend
my friend bumped into him at foxborough
mall he didn't do nothing so
that is so true about boston i was i was
in boston a couple years ago and i went
to use the men's room staying in a hotel
i go to use the men's room which is off
the bar and this
i want to say an older woman with a
really thick
accent comes into the men's room and
goes conan
come on in and i went excuse me it's a
men's room at the euro and she went oh
mr big shot you're like what are you
talking about
it's called i met a urinal with my dick
out
[Laughter]
oh the high and mighty hollywood where
old ladies aren't allowed to come into a
men's room and talk to you while you're
peeing it's insanity